let's take one more call it is the first
day in 2017 that we are taking live
calls we will take one more call from
the 631 area code 631 what's your name
and where are you calling from
hey David my name's Bryan I'm calling
from London our small island great
what's on your mind hey I just wanted to
ask have you been watching a Bill
O'Reilly lately no you know I mentioned
earlier in the week that now because of
all the the news digest email
newsletters I'm on I basically don't
have to watch Fox at all but I did tune
in five minutes the other day to Fox &
Friends and thought it was Saturday
Night Live but why what's been going on
on Bill O'Reilly lately oh very
obviously intoxicated on air like and I
think it stemmed from you know his his
wife yeah they got a divorce and she
doesn't have visitation rights for his
kids because this case went to court and
said that he dragged his wife down the
stairs by her hair I remember the
allegation about that yeah he's just a
downward spiral I don't understand how
they could put someone in the air was so
obviously intoxicated becomes a joke
obviously I can't comment on whether
what I obviously I don't know whether
what's being alleged here is true but if
there's a particular date night show
watch you two clips I'm okay you could
you could you could find it it's
hilarious but yeah I just wanted um I
want to ask you a question if you had
the power to let's say just you know
magically impeach Trump and that would
make tents truck president would you do
that I don't think I would and I've
talked about this before that if we put
pence in you've all of a sudden got a
guy who's way more ideological and way
more politically skilled in terms of how
Washington works and I think that if
there's any firm that will prevent the
Republicans of 2017 through 2021 from
operating as extremist religious
conservatives it's that Trump isn't one
and they'll sort of have to work with
him on on some of the issues where he's
not an ideological religious
conservative so if you tell me the only
options are its Trump or it's pence I
actually say keep Trump I'm more worried
about foreign policy with Trump and I
would be more worried about the mess
policy repents because Trump is an
obvious narcissist yeah and if his name
gets dragged down by bad policies and
you know bad economy you know he's very
active on Twitter and he kind of
responds to that I think if in this you
know his name's on the old hotel tents
doesn't care Paul Ryan doesn't care I
mean the nine percent approval rating
Congress doesn't care they don't respond
to that at all
yeah that's a good point splitting it up
that way makes sense unbalanced though I
would not want Mike Pence to be
President of the US hey always great to
hear from Long Island by the way the
home of Bill O'Reilly none other thanks
so much for the call really appreciate
it thank you David take care man all
right that's going to do it for calls
for us this week a lot of interesting
topics clearly on the minds of our
audience six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty is always the number
when we take calls we'll take a break
and be back with more after this